Benjamin tu es plutôt ange ou démon
Benjamin
j'aime bien tout ce qui est un peu
sensuel chaud sexy donc j'adore tu mets
tout le monde mal à l'aise là
[Rires]
des robots on mange tes morts
cette année avec son déguisement
d'Halloween oui c'est bien la mannequin
de 49 ans qui se cache dans ce costume
de ver de terre
à lombric à la fois dégoûtant et
impressionnant bref idéal pour être la
reine de la soirée
je fais Abraham qui est le propriétaire
de leur appartement je fais un
personnage qui s'appelle Gédéon enfin
que j'ai appelé Gédéon et qui a un petit
personnage qui est un agriculteur qui
part à la guerre je fais le roi
d'Espagne le roi de France la duchesse
de montagne
cartés qui est donc le fidèle destrier
en quelque sorte du Montespan
Macron Macron le fameux bacon il pense
vraiment qu'Emmanuel Macron et de gauche
au Brésil
ah oui ils en sont tous convaincus pour
eux c'est même un communiste tu vois
ils sont assez mal informés je crois
Maëlle est étudiante à Sciences Po
originaire de Mayotte elle dit que le
montant de sabourse baisse chaque année
et j'ai 100 € de bourse par mois et avec
ça je suis censé vivre
puis mes courses payer mon loyer avec un
père au chômage et une mère qui touche
2000 euros par mois impossible pour ses
parents de les défis financièrement pour
vivre elle travaille 20 heures par
semaine touché par cette vidéo une
internaute a lancé une cagnotte en
quelques heures plus de 14000 euros ont
été récoltés en fait ce qui est dans le
livre c'est que le personnage s'appelle
réellement et historiquement Jean nous
la confirmé maquereau et nous on s'est
permis un petit pas de côté à partir de
là évidemment ça s'appelle la question
ils ont chacun un cachet par
le personnage j'ai payé bien sûr
[Rires]
cette semaine Paul Sky est Toutatice se
sont rendus dans un restaurant parisien
avec cette tenue je veux bien que ça
soit pas hyper couvert mais c'est pas
non plus un maillot de bain enfin je
sais pas une tenue jugée inappropriée
par le restaurateur qui leur a refusé
l'entrée
eux ont des déguisements très bons c'est
aux États-Unis le couple baiden a
célébré Halloween et c'était très bien
ils ont mis les petits plats dans les
grands Gilles Biden avait une perruque
violette mais oui bien sûr c'est vrai
c'était hier et Joe Biden était grimé en
zombie de walkie dead alors on me dit
dans l'oreillette que c'est pas un
déguisement voilà mais c'était une très
très belle fête tu sais ce qu'on dit sur
les Noirs faute noire oui sur les Arabes
sur les Belges sur les Juifs faut avoir
un bon avocat
oui la discrimination tenue correcte
exigée où est le problème
il y a pas de scandale il a pas envie
d'avoir des nanas qui sont à moitié dans
son restaurant et ben il a bien raison
de le dire et de le faire après elles
reviennent elles se font filmer c'est du
buzz effectivement à deux balles et il y
a 0 scandale il y a des devoir du mal
partout vous vous êtes vraiment à côté
de la plaque définitivement comme
toujours voilà
bonsoir à la une de ce 2 novembre
avertissement suite au rachat de la
pastille par Elon Musk pour continuer à
suivre la BC veuillez régler la somme de
8 dollars par mois pour vous abonner
c'est très simple vous n'avez qu'à
entrer vos coordonnées bancaires vous
cliquez
non personne
et ben demain Babette pas sur les
réseaux sociaux vous ce type étude
pour éviter que l'utilisent
voilà ce type est ignoble c'est une
horreur c'est l'ultralibéralisme dans
tout ce qui est plus objects de
dégueulasse
sont déjà
vous avez des fils qui s'exhibent sur
les réseaux sociaux qui ont envie et
vous critiquez dans jeunes femmes un
fils qui vit des réseaux sociaux
au restaurant
je suis pris dans le grenade
depuis que je suis votre collaborateur
ma chérie Estelle je sens pour Twitter
passer tous les jours et quelques fois
ça race ça passera du mais c'est très
bien et ça m'a permis aussi d'échanger
de voilà de donner son avis quand on a
envie on devient con c'est terrible avec
du terre c'est terrible que ça peut être
un bêtisant imaginer que dans un avenir
prochain plein de jeunes 2 ans de moins
de 18 ans et des téléphones en
permanence sur eux je dirais si on va si
loin ça paraît fou parce qu'il faudrait
des fils de plusieurs kilomètres
imaginé un truc où tous les jeunes et un
téléphone et qu'on puisse les appeler
n'importe où n'a pas peur Dieu nous en
garde
j'aimerais le mot de la fin de Paul Sky
Toutatice alors Toutatice
[Rires]